roselyne febvre vous êtes notre
spécialiste de politique française que
peut-on attendre de cette rencontre
entre les deux anciens présidents et
l'actuel chef de l'état bah c'est
symbolique alors symbolique dans le sens
où emmanuel macron est à la recherche
bien évidemment de l'unité nationale et
puis pour montrer aussi que la situation
va au delà des enjeux partisans et
politiques de la scène politique
française et puis c'est une façon aussi
de recourir à peut-être aux conseils des
deux précédents de ses deux
prédécesseurs qui ont eu affaire à
lui ce que ça a été rappelé par karim et
en 2008 avec la géorgie pour nicolas
sarkozy et
françois hollande avec merkel sur le
dombass entre 14 entre 2014 et 2015 et
vous avez réclamé un cessez-le-feu et
vous avez mis en place le format
normandie où il avait mis en place
absolument le format normandie déjà donc
il ya une expérience 1 on peut dire que
les deux anciens présidents de la
république sont passés par les mêmes
errements on va dire peut-être avec le
président russe et qu'ils peuvent voilà
lui donner quelques conseils en tout cas
sur la psychologie et sur la façon dont
fonctionne le président russe et puis
c'est une on va dire une bonne manière
républicaine de recevoir les anciens
présidents qui sans doute on va
peut-être demander à vouloir s'exprimer
aussi par ailleurs quel est l'impact de
cette guerre en ukraine actuellement sur
la campagne présidentielle
eh bien écoutez la campagne
présidentielle dès le premier tour a
lieu au miles eh oui la campagne
présidentielle était déjà inexistante
donc complètement atone donc aujourd'hui
elle est complètement grignotée par part
bien sûr le conflit en ukraine
alors là si on est si on avait espéré
qu'il se passe quelque chose en tout cas
sur la scène française et bien que cette
campagne prennent un peu de corps et
justement on attendait qu emmanuel
macron se déclare pour que cette
campagne que la fusée maintenance
d'école et qu'on puisse commencer cette
campagne eh bien je crois que c'est
fichu puisque il va falloir attendre le
4 mars puisque la emmanuel macron et
dans le rôle du président est bien
évidemment personne va lui demander dans
le rôle du candidat et est ce que cette
posture finalement ne conforte pas le
chef de l'état et empêche quand même la
tenue de la campagne bruno retailleau
qui est une figure quand même de la
droite et qui est dans le staff de
campagne de valérie pécresse la
candidate pour l'opposition et l'air a
déclaré cette stratégie de mâcon de tuer
la campagne en à feu n'ont pas c'est un
déni démocratique
ouais enfin bon
d'accord enfin il déclare ça alors qu'il
ya quand même une guerre aux portes de
l'europe moi je veux bien qu'on soit sur
son petit nombril mais je suis désolé il
ya une guerre à des décisions à prendre
le président en personne ne va lui faire
reproche de passer son temps à régler
cette attente et de
malheureusement personne ne peut rien
mais en tout cas de tenter
d'aider des raids on va dire
diplomatique ou en tout cas de
discussion ça il ne sera absolument pas
reprocher donc franchement c'est là
aussi c'est pas au niveau je trouve de
la classe politique de piquer sur ce
genre de souche mais le prime rosine
c'est le résultat à l'europe à jouer le
plus longtemps possible la carte
diplomatique pour éviter la guerre
est-ce que néanmoins le président
français emmanuel macron n'a pas été
imprudent lorsqu'il a annoncé une
réunion au sommet entre vladimir poutine
et joe biden démentie quelques heures
après quelques heures après par le
kremlin oui oui cet élu c'est peut-être
un peu emballé un peu vide c'est vrai
qu'à retourner dans le feu de l'action
peut-être que voilà peut-être qu'il y
croyait lui-même alors certains disent
il a péché par naïveté et d'autres
disent bah voila il sait il vola il a
voulu communiquer sur quelque chose qui
était pas vraiment bétonné comme on dit
bon
oui c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu
s'abstenir de d'annoncer quelque chose
qui ne s'est pas fait donc c'est la
prudence aussi parfois d'apprendre cette
prudence en diplomatie et à dire que
seuls les résultats comptent et là force
est de constater que voilà rien ne s'est
passé en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que vous pour répondre à votre
question sur la posture du président de
la république ça a en tout cas permis de
deux de voir que certains comme marine
le pen eric zemmour jean luc mélenchon
on a envie de se demander s'il faut leur
donner les clés de costume de chef des
armées parce que il ya quelques jours
mélenchon disait que c'était l'amérique
qui agressait bon aujourd'hui les
condamne la russie il ya quelques temps
il ya le 30 janvier eric zemmour dit je
suis prêt à parier devant vous ne pas
dire il n'y aura pas d'invasion de la la
russie donc tout ça en plus ils ont
plutôt été magnanimes ces trois
personnages pour des raisons différentes
mélenchon parce que antiaméricains et
marine le pen par eric zemmour parce
qu'ils admirent les autocrates on va
dire donc tout ça et est en train de les
décrédibiliser à mon sens merci beaucoup
roselyne febvre d'être venu merci